you went real fast from
the first visual introduction to deepti
um
you had this like look of astonishment
on your face i think is the best way to
put it and you went real quick from
i want to put babies in you right now to
i feel like i'm dating my aunt
and i know what that's like because i've
dated a chick before that reminded me of
a cousin and i was just like
i can't do it i can't do it
well thanks for saying that yeah i mean
people like were ready to bash me for
for having that feeling but i think it's
a feeling that we've all had in one way
or another you know someone reminds me
of my cousin or my or my coworker or
like just somebody else right
um but yeah okay let me answer your
question so
when i first saw her
i i was thrilled with what i saw okay so
we'd formed such a deep
connection in the pods and we were so
you know so close emotionally
and
when i saw her
with all the like hype built around it
that you know the cameras are all there
the lights the red carpet like it's
built up so much you know
i and when i saw her visually i i was
attracted i was like oh wow she's she's
pretty like i'm attracted to this person
right now
and all the emotions hyped that up even
more and
it was a very pure moment there was no
there was no faking it
or or anything there okay
um
but
those kind of like hyped-up moments
those really high highs they're not real
you know what i mean
um once
let's see
to note there's chemistry
you have to spend some time in the lab
you know
right and so that just wasn't enough
time in the lab like we had that was
like a
15-minute thing and then we didn't see
each other for a couple days until we
were in mexico which is probably another
like strategy like okay like let it
build up in their minds and you know
they want to capture every moment
together so
once once we
got to mexico
it's it's different like now we're like
kind of almost expected to have this
physical connection right and the
cameras are on and everything else
i'll say this
i guess in past relationships i've been
i've been a little spoiled i guess
almost like the the girl i was dating
before deeps
tiny blonde six-pack like great shape
you know
um
and that was
that was great i kind of got used to
that so to speak
so
once we had this pool scene there's like
really no really gentle way to say this
like once we had this pool scene you
know
at first i'm like okay hey
maybe this is something i can kind of
work past like hey the whole point of
the show is to kind of like get past
this
physical get past what you know what
somebody looks like and fall in love
with their personality i've often said
like nobody nobody gets excited about
[ __ ] somebody else's personality like
you know i can't [ __ ] a nice personality
right but that's what they're trying to
get you guys to do right is to fall in
love with the personality and forget
what they look like
yeah yeah basically and and i'll tell
you this she's and i still find her
pretty i still think she's pretty but
like
once you know you're like if you're in
like say a pool together and you're like
up and close and like feeling each other
your body is going to either respond or
it's not going to respond right like
it's not it's not even something you
think about because like even then i'm
like looking at her i'm like okay yeah
she's a pretty girl she's a pretty girl
but
we are animals you know i know they kind
of came after me for this but we we are
animals like we have biologic cues that
we pick up on and like subconsciously
act on and those those cues in this case
you know they weren't there for me and
that's that's when i kind of knew pretty
fast because that's not something that
kind of develops over time
no it's there right away yeah
it's absolutely the right way i mean you
know often uh within the first few
seconds you know when you see them
especially if they're wearing the right
clothing and the lighting's good like
you'll know right away absolutely
um you're 100 right so
i mean
the whole premise of the show was to
stick a man and a woman in these pods
with a wall between you
and then you kind of like chop it up
like you just sort of have conversations
um
they showed obviously clips of
highlights that they wanted to show how
much time did you guys actually spend in
the pods talking to each other in total
um so it was about 10 days
i want to say
um
and as you kind of
moved along as you made connections you
would spend longer and longer with the
people you made connections with so so
would you like reserve time with
somebody that you wanted to see again
you know sort of thing and they would
put you
together with that person it we didn't
have as much control um i mean we did
get we had a say in who we wanted to see
but but there was also an aspect that
they were controlling so like when you
went in and you'd hear their voice and
you figured out who it was you'd be like
really happy like oh it's my person or
or oh this is not one of the people that
i'm super interested in maybe we'll just
kind of like keep it polite and like
hang out for a little bit i saw that
they kind of put shane on the spot at
one point and
swapped out like natalie for shayna and
he thought it was the other girl and
there was that big drama that unfolded
because of it like that was part of the
production
yeah i think that was that was his own
fault honestly because it's never where
you like expect somebody like you know
from the beginning that you
you don't know until you're in there
talking to them and like part of the fun
of it is you go in there you
try and figure out who it is based on
their voice and usually you can pretty
quick
so
yeah there's no like switcheroo that
could really happen i mean
um
yeah did they end up telling you guys to
stay away from questions that would lead
towards um the optics of attraction
height weight hair length hair color
stuff like that because i mean like you
were clever about it because you're all
like hey you know i like music festivals
uh i like putting girls on my shoulders
at music festivals would i have a
problem putting you on my shoulder at a
music festival sort of thing
yeah well um they they kind of said
remember what the point of the show is
kind of like that like it was like i
don't care
i need to know what she looks like
yeah i mean i i for both of our sakes i
didn't want to be in a situation where
i was so far out of the ballpark of my
physical range that like it's like okay
now it's really a waste of time you know
and i tried to say that at the reunion
too i was like hey i want to get in the
ballpark i wanted it to work you know
for the initial stages
you know i believed in
this maybe working and i wanted to give
it a fair shot
um looking back now i'm like okay
i don't know that
you know the point of the show was to
like
clown on people once you know once they
you know
put themselves out there now i get that
but at some point i
i believed in the show for you know what
they were claiming hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you